surprising thing about nor macdonald is  not his voice but his material but his  early jokes are a lot different from his  older ones well i love the tv i saw a  cat food commercial i said at the end of  it said all natural food for your cat  all natural food  but cat food's made out of horse meat  yeah that's the way it works in nature  the the cat right above the horse in the  food chain  what started as silly cat food jokes  later became people commit suicide  people go i don't understand why and i  go you don't  well you live in a cotton candy house or  something what the [ __ ]  you don't know about life  now it only disappoints and  gets worse and worse until it ends in a  catastrophe  the greats bring light to the dark and  comedy's brightest voice will forever be  norm mcdonald